Gunter holthoff says when his wife
Allison started feeling sick on New
Year's Eve he decided to bring her to
the Cumberland Regional Health Care
Center out of fear the ambulance would
take too long he says he carried her
into the car and once they arrived her
pain started to get worse he says his
wife was scared the thing she actually
said started saying that she was felt
like she was dying in the waiting room
outside
but but she kept saying it more and more
she said um I feel like I'm dying
they're going to let me die here and I
just told her like no that's why they
got you in the hospital hold off says he
continued to tell staff her health was
deteriorating I did go up to the nurse
station and did tell them that that
she told me she feels like she's dying
she's getting worse
I don't know what the response were I
don't I don't really recall but but I
don't think there was much of a response
he and Cumberland North MLA Elizabeth
Smith mccrossen are calling for an
investigation into the case we have a
responsibility to provide the people of
this province with safe and reliable
timely health care and I am expecting
for this family to receive some
compassion and caring and to get some
help and support in a statement Health
Minister Michelle Thompson calls to
death a tragic loss and says Nova Scotia
health is investigating the case it's
really important that we do a quality
review to understand
what happened and how do we work uh to
to ensure that it is prevented in the
future she assures Nova scotians they
will act on what they learn from the
probe holthoff describes his wife as
someone who is always willing to lend a
helping hand the mother of three took
care of everything while he was working
out west from their hobby firm to their
kids and the community through her role
as tidnesh Bridge of fire and rescue
deputy chief she was always happy to
help people and provide people with a
safe spot like we have a little hobby
Farm going there which was just supposed
to be oh just get one sheep and then oh
well they're Hood animals so you need
two and then every time we brought them
some have to get shown it usually came
back with an extra sheep or two so
bring her story with the hope that a
case
[Applause]